valais pelle et solidarité une armée de
jeunes ont envahi les quartiers les plus
touchées par la double explosion dans le
port de beyrouth aujourd'hui c'est le
moment de se retrousser les manches pour
ne pas sombrer et être paralysée par le
désespoir
tony moussalem revenait dans ses bureaux
qui font face au port pour la première
fois depuis le sinistre
j'ai du mal à exprimer mes sentiments
dit il je suis en colère triste je me
sens vide
en fait je n'ai pas les mots un peu des
dizaines de personnes restent portées
disparues et les recherches se
poursuivent même si l'espoir quitte les
familles avec le temps qui passe
zahia bencheikh est sans nouvelle de son
mari il travaillait dans le silo de
grains du port au moment des
déflagrations et l'attend sous un soleil
de plomb qu'on lui apporte des réponses
ou du moins le corps du père de ses
trois enfants
il gagne un peu moins de 5 dollars par
jour pour son labeur ils n'ont pas
d'empathie pour les pauvres dit elle il
les appelle juste quand ils en ont
besoin et quand il arrive un problème à
eux sont confortablement chez eux ne
sont ils pas responsable de tout ce qui
nous arrive dit elle des dirigeants et
secouristes sont venus de partout dans
le monde pour prêter main forte aux
équipiers dannez un petit groupe d'entre
eux a été saluée par les
applaudissements de la foule
en traversant un quartier sinistré
elle est donc bienvenu cette aide
internationale elle apporte un baume au
liban qui en a cruellement besoin l'aide
d'accord nous disent les gens ici mais
l'argent de l'étranger lui n'est pas le
bienvenu s'il est pour une fois de plus
atterrir dans les poches de leurs
dirigeants font remonter de michel
d'état visité le liban pour témoigner de
la sympathie de la france envers la
souffrance du peuple libanais et lui
offrir de l'aide
emmanuel macron en a bien entendu les
foules massées pour le rencontrer c'est
pour se débarrasser des dirigeants qu'il
souhaite de lège et c'est mon devoir
pour vous aider en tant que peuple la
france veut coordonner l'aide de la
communauté internationale
il est dirigeant libanais devront faire
des changements profonds à leur gestion
du pays a prévenu le président français
d'après les autorités libanaises ce sont
quelques deux mille sept cent cinquante
tonnes de nitrate d'ammonium stockées
sans mesure de protection dans le port
de la ville qui sont à l'origine de la
déflagration
beaucoup de libanais eux remontent la
piste bien au delà des explosifs
c'est le système ses dirigeants et le
hezbollah qui sont responsables de tout
une mafia du temps dans le quartier de
gemmayzé il ya une équation au liban qui
s'appelle mapei maëlys il s'embarque du
pays et le contrôle le pays les gens
payent le prix
les pauvres payent l'opérer
on veut plus de ça les appels à la
vengeance se font de plus en plus sonore
entre le bruit des débris et du verre
fracassée et sortir des chiens dans les
rues et en ferme nous dans ces cellules
championnat à l'endroit du gouvernement
labour plus rien à craindre
plus rien à perdre